if you if we if the black community
especially and I can't speak for them
but I'm gonna speak for government
mm-hmm if the black community
communities of color are relying on the
federal government are relying on
left-wing or right-wing anybody if
they're relying on that you tell me how
that's been going for the last 50 years
right so so my question is yeah and I
think the debates happening already in
the black community what does the black
community do it's like that famous quote
by Malcolm X who said if somebody throws
you in a hole don't expect the person
who threw you into a hole to pull you
out of the hole right and I think that's
as relevant as so what is do that so
what does the black man I think you not
even have a plan I think to be honest
with you black community are our biggest
you know we're our own nemesis you know
obviously police brutality is a huge
thing but I think the fact that we don't
come United on any fronts and this is
not to speak down but the Asian
community they have each other's back
the Jewish community have each other
back the Mexican community have each
other back - that doesn't mean the whole
time they're always agreeing or loving
so to speak our community our neighbors
our brothers our sisters but would they
understand that you know you sacrifice
this time now that you know you're gonna
have you know you're gonna be well off
later and I think the black community
never really has unity so to me coming
together first and foremost you know
what I mean just coming together
realizing that hey we're all in this
fight together and that's blacks first
but then everyone else who wants to
follow us I think that's great as well
but then having a plan understanding
voting you know when we say vote it's
not just if everyone wants to Trump out
of the white house it's not about
getting trumped by the white house
although I think that's important but to
me it's voting on your local and state
level because that's where all the bills
are greatly been passed and people to
understand that you know understanding
you know who your council members are
you know the mayors and how important
District Attorney's are you know
district attorneys got their pockets
wide open like you said everyone has a
hand to the police officers there was a
situation where I did a stuff the Stefan
Clarke rally in Sacramento two years ago
when the cops shot him eight times six
times in the back no one was charged but
right before the the Amory Schubert the
crooked DEA in Sacramento was supposed
to make a ruling she got a four hundred
thousand dollar donation from the SAC PD
and and I'm remiss cuz I I was thinking
myself is up to date on stuff I I have I
was talking to somebody was involved in
local politics I came here and told you
this I felt like a white belt I didn't
know [ __ ] yeah I there's no excuse eyes
it's a lot thank you years to why that's
something I mean I eventually want to be
mayor of my hometown so I'm doing a lot
of stuff in Sacramento working with you
know bringing businesses there and
working with the mayor and the police
chief to kind of bridge the gap on
certain projects but you know I just had
an amazing meeting with the guy named
Richard green yesterday and I had
probably bought five or six you know
urban platform you know people have big
platforms in our urban space and we're
trying to teach pot like make politics
fun you know make it under so people
understand how important and it's not so
much about say oh I don't like politics
it's crooked that you know the
Republicans and Democrats are I mean
everyone is politics is nasty
you know you can't say Democrats are
good and they'd always do good and or
you know vice versa sort of it's all
nasty in there but be passionate about a
cause like something you're passionate
about like just vote for that you know
you register and vote for that cause you
whatever you feel is near and dear to
your heart whatever touches you because
we can't make everyone want to vote for
the president or want to vote for
certain things but they're I guarantee
if everyone looks into you know the
election and things are up for debate
and think that we have control over the
community you can find a handful of
thing that you're passionate about it
and vote about those things that's
starting out right and then still that's
when you start with that then you start
learning more and understanding you know
once you learn politics it's very
interesting and realizing how much power
we do have especially as the black
community and then minorities as a whole
you know if we all came together and
understood how important it is
I love the word marching and rally and I
didn't really like the burning down the
buildings and looting and all that [ __ ]
but to me
we've been peacefully protesting cap
took a knee we've been putting our fists
up peacefully for 400 years and Nestle
and nothing happens so for the first
time now the world finally hears us you
know so what's so after now that they
hear us what is the next step you know
what's the plan now we have to happen
right you know to mean so for the first
time
everyone has our attention you see huge
four and five fortune 500 companies
saying stuff donating money and this is
not the first black man's been killed
this shit's been happening for a long
time before it's finally like the one
like you said that was the cherry on top
like we saw someone be executed in front
of our own eyes
you know so forth and even with that
being said there's still people that
want to bring up his past and his
upbringing and he was this is he
that's not for $20 [ __ ] you know not
for $20 especially when you have these
these young white kids that are doing
these mass shootings that are getting
taken to Burger King you know should
know we're also like not that it matters
at all but they were cocaine convictions
a lot of times you get coke on him and
stuff skater another stuff matters what
I was telling people was I mean you can
be a vegan yogi healthiest person world
if someone puts the knee on your neck
for nine minutes you're gonna die you
[ __ ] how healthy you are never wrestle
with him haven't grabbed a grizzly bear
use it's just forgive him give 30
seconds and tell me we don't talk about
how uncomfortable just to lay on your
stomach period you know to mute on the
road on the ground you're on family oh
you and then you had your body's not
going through crazy stuff - you're
laying on the ground with you have one
guy on you've been to other guys on you
is that so bad realize - that the show
you do all the smoke which I think it's
fair to say and I go out I go out
internet trolls all the time with this
you guys literally have the biggest by
far basketball show and you won't just
talk sports in gaming it's up there
maybe I was just talking about boy Brian
daily about the sailor daming you guys
show so big so big and your partner on
that show Stephen Josh and Stax he was
really close in the mix yeah people
don't realize it yeah called a twin his
twin yeah he looks like most identical I
didn't know there obviously the
relationship they had until it happened
and Jack and I have been speaking co-ed
because two weeks ago yeah I think he
bought them collecting out clothes and
stuff like just sends a bunch I mean we
get so much stuff and then you know we
go through so much so that you know I I
have people I donate to all the time so
that that was someone that Jack would
just give you know when we stuff we
don't like or done wearing or something
we don't nary into you know donate to
suffer six-foot-seven right you know I
mean it's hard to give it away you know
so that was you know come to find out
that was Jack's brother and it was I've
just been so proud of him because you
know I've been in this space to social
justice space speaking up on it for a
long time and it really weighs on you
but he really jumped in the middle of a
frying pan like this is this like he
says it's a revolution you know what I
mean and he's at the forefront of it
speaking on it bringing people together
consulting the family doing everything
he absolutely can with this platform to
bring attention to the
scram from each in and it's and it's
it's draining you know I had on the
other day it's just like you know you
can't let this consume you make sure
you're getting rest getting some sleep
you know smoking turning off your
electronics and just taking time for you
because this hurts you know what I mean
like I don't care what color you are
like you're feeling what's going on
right now and I've been on top I get I
get for me I feel like I can't do
anybody could do you know there's not
much anybody can do but just it got to a
point where you know I was on top of it
I was posting all the police brutality
stuff and all the negativity and I yeah
yeah it's a like a lot of people are
jumping on it right which it's good
you're coming around but I've been on
this 400 yeah and but I mean I to the
point like I had to erase all the stuff
that I was posting just because I was
just tired of just seeing negativity
like it just hurts it wears you out I
want to ask you this cuz I've been
reading a lot about let me go there's a
picture of stack so where he has the
Boyd's baby girl on the shoulder yeah
this is she says it's gonna change the
world do if that doesn't connect you hit
you where it hurts me mmm-hmm daddy
things the world that doesn't do
something to you all right
your sociopath yeah no it's right
let me ask you this man
I've been listening to a lot of black
scholars and reading you know Larry
elders Thomas Sol I listen to Candace
Owens it's got some stuff to say for
sure she just employs she's just so
strong about rubes her point of view
that it's like but listen you know she's
I still think she's a valid voice and
one of the things I never [ __ ] hear
CNN talk about and people talk about I
can't say anything but there are certain
issues within any community any
community in any culture that work then
and don't work now and if and one of the
things that Larry elders said which I
thought was kind of hit me and I was
like damn is he said in the 1960s a
black child was 80% likely to be born to
a two-parent household today it's
reversed they're gonna merge and when
that happens when a child is born to a
single mother you have a 5% thought
you're five times more likely to be
under the poverty line you're nine times
more likely to end up in jail you're 20
times more likely mean the statues so
[ __ ] like I don't hear CNN and places
like that talking enough about that
which which as Canas owns Larry elders
Thomas hall said if you want to talk
about martyrs these dumbass racists and
Charlotte's felt you know they're always
there you know there that's what she
said that's a far less I'm way less
worried about those dum-dums
because there are 25 of them there may
be a bunch but I'm more worried about
that situation anger there and those are
the things that I think about and I go
why why is nobody talk we got to talk
about that not because it's a criticism
or just because that makes sense to me
you want it's much easier to have to be
you and I have kids
we have kids about the same age you know
hum how much you have to rely on mom but
how much the kids rely on you but so at
the same time I'm a single dad but I'm
just very involved I got my mom in my
kids lives in and I think you bring up a
great point for not only the black
community but community is all even when
you're born to just one parent and
another parents not if all you're gonna
be behind that's a white problem - by
the way I had some say Robin then people
want a quick to say well there's you
know the black
black remember majority problem you
interact with people in your community
so if your whole community is black when
you have commits ups and communities and
you kill each other it's gonna be that
the same thing in the white community
when you have mix up in the white
community that's what your around us so
you're going to end up killing Mexicans
and so on and so forth but you know
there's definitely it goes to say you
know it's deeper like we're always
seeing the end result we're seeing the
killings and everything but it's it's
just it's obviously a deeper root we
didn't with the wreckage of our past
here right you know what I mean and like
you said for for anyone for any black
people to think that we're getting
reparations is crazy
they'd they're not handing a [ __ ] you
know we have to come out with the plan
and do it ourselves you know and I think
what we have is when we unite and
understand and have one voice people
understand we have the same turnout in
November that from the minority
community that there was when Obama was
elected president that Trump will get
blown out of the water and people don't
realize that you know what I mean if we
really come together and go out there
and vote that we can get Trump out of
the White House if that's what people's
goals are but like I said we've just
kind of always been on islands and never
United Network but is that the goal Matt
you think if you get Trump out so to me
the whole thing with me is you know
anyone understand because people
understand the the ordinance of power
Trump the Obama Trump presidents don't
have that much power it's the Supreme
Court yeah people don't understand that
like a good point
the presidents really like when Trump
says he's gonna do stuff people kind of
look crazy because if you know he
doesn't have that kind of power you know
people say about people still go crazy
but if you understand and study up he
can only do so much the president
they're not the most Mitch McConnell's
the most powerful man that's you know I
mean people don't understand how things
go so it's not so much that Trump is the
prosper like this is happening because
him I'm just from up from a point of you
spew too much hate you can be you could
have been great you could use more
divided you're a fire you can be great
at bringing the economy back and doing
things here and there but to me I face
so much races going up and I think hard
that the state of our country has built
on hate so when you're someone that
won't come out in an essay say the
n-word or this or that but you use dog
whistle
terms of back in the day I would knock
them out or carry them on the stretcher
or the good old days like to me your
rhetoric is talking right to those
people they bit hate us write that your
your your dog whistling those people so
I don't care how great he's been on any
of the other fronts we just need someone
if it's not gonna spew hate you know we
need every rights we're more divided now
than we've ever been and it's
unfortunate because you don't wear the
black community or the country in
general the country in general is
divided the black community is someone
always been divided you know means so
that bets are they say it's important to
remember that when you say black
community look West Indian blacks are
very different than Nigerian blacks are
very different than ebo and Yoruba backs
are very different than then a black guy
a black family from Mississippi that
super religious is believe me very
different than a black doctors family in
New York it's very different so that's
why the the the black vote when people
say that stuff and I talked about this
my last special it's all over the
[ __ ] place if you go to Africa daddy
there's such a difference between go
tells somebody who's Sudanese that he
he's like somebody who's from Ethiopia
and they border the same country good
luck with that much there's a lot of
even there's a lot of internal hate to
from all races but particularly someone
the black because we struggle with
colorism oh my god
darker people don't like lighters
sometimes I say lighter people think
they're better than darker and like in
the day like we're all first of all
humid but we're all the different color
than you you have me so why not in when
I say us it's even you know there's
tension between you know uh you know
Mexicans and blacks you mean but were
them we get treated the worse so I'm a
genetic okay we have a consistent we
come together let's try to come together
and sorry come together and really fight
the real enemy
let's fight racism to me it's everybody
wears racism because not oh I'm a half
Italian and black like I don't claim to
combo was a time Motel you see you're
facing a lot of racism I'm sure can you
get from both sides right yeah I was
never wide enough and I was never black
enough you know I mean I was never dark
enough and my hair looked like this so
you're not I get from black people like
what are you like everyone thought I was
Mexican for the long girls hey
tell me about hey when you're six seven
without hair no it was hard for you
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]